quelle est votre relation avec votre
pied gauche maintenant
[Rires]
après la ressemblance insupportable d'être
dirigé avec une vue et ma belle
laverie
vous avez décidé de ne pas faire un autre film
jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez le bon scénario
combien de temps étiez-vous prêt à attendre
je ne sais pas  sais
comme il s'est avéré que j'ai attendu un an
aurait pu être deux trois quatre cinq je
ne sais pas comment tu as mis le contact
avec le scénario de mon pied gauche ça
vient d'arriver un soir
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas d'avertissement il n'y avait pas
appel téléphonique pas de lettre il est juste tombé
dans la boîte aux lettres un soir
euh
il commençait à faire sombre et je
n'avais pas allumé les lumières
dans la maison et j'ai entendu le bruit de
quelque chose de lourd atterrir sur le tapis et j'ai
trouvé ce
script blanc brillant  sur le paillasson et
j'ai commencé à le lire
c'était euh c'était comme une météorite
tu as dit que tu devais savoir ce que tu
voulais faire et combien tu étais prêt
à souffrir pour le faire
combien étais-tu prêt à souffrir pour
faire  mon pied gauche je  supposons à certains
égards que mon pied gauche était plus exigeant
qu'autre chose
mais cela m'a aussi donné beaucoup plus
pourquoi avez-vous décidé d'être roulé ou
porté pendant les six semaines de prise de vue de
mon pied gauche j'ai juste choisi une façon de
travailler qui me semblait  à l'époque,
c'était la seule voie possible, je n'avais pas l'impression de
choisir entre des alternatives
plutôt que d'agir, vous semblez occuper d'
autres vies pendant un certain temps ouais, je
pense que
je suis plus intéressé par les vies qui
me semblent  être à une certaine distance du
mien plus la distance est grande plus
je suis intéressé quelle est votre
relation avec votre pied gauche maintenant
[Rires]
Je pense que nous sommes des connaissances très très proches
qui n'ont pas la chance de se
rencontrer si souvent qu'en est-il
entretiens de promotion
Je pense que les acteurs en particulier sont
encouragés à parler beaucoup trop
du travail qu'ils font et je pense
qu'au final c'est préjudiciable à la
façon dont ce travail est perçu
donc si je pouvais éviter le plus
souvent je le ferais  n'est-ce pas  il est significatif que
vos personnages semblent toujours avoir
des problèmes de communication
oui c'est probablement le cas
je ne pense pas que quelqu'un m'ait jamais fait
remarquer cela mais je pense que c'est
probablement ouais
quels souvenirs garderez-vous de la
cérémonie des Oscars à part le Billy Crystal
crack
ils étaient bons mais n'étaient-ils pas je
suppose que l'arrivée
l'arrivée à euh l'endroit où
cet événement s'est produit je me souviens parce
que c'était on pouvait l'entendre
de loin c'était comme entrer
dans une arène de gladiateurs d'une sorte que
vous pourriez  entendre des
foules de gens crier et hurler
et puis euh
il fallait prendre sa place dans un
embouteillage à quatre voies de voitures extrêmement grosses
qui se dégorgeaient mais
euh contenu petit à petit puis
défiler à travers ce Gauntlet de
photographes journalistes public
tout le monde crie pour attirer l'attention  Je me
souviendrai que c'est
ce qui a fait une impression
euh
je suppose
que tout le
reste de cette soirée a
vraiment pâli en insi  gniificance après
le moment où euh que le prix a été
annoncé parce qu'il a eu un tel
effet physique sur moi que je pouvais à
peine monter les escaliers et je
même si j'essayais d'anticiper l'
éventualité de peut-être gagner ce
prix, je n'aurais jamais pu deviner  que ça
aurait ce genre d'effet et
c'était très choquant c'était en fait
comme être dans un accident de voiture ou
quelque chose
comme ça ce serait votre prochain film ou pièce
je ne sais pas
je suis de retour je suis de retour à la place  celui où je suis de retour
à l'endroit où j'étais avant de me faire
quel personnage rêvez-vous d'être
sur scène ou à l'écran la vérité est que
je n'ai jamais eu d'
ambitions spécifiques pour l'avenir
que devez-vous à votre  famille et qui
étaient-ils je suppose à mon père avant
tout je dois
euh
une certaine compréhension et un amour pour la
poésie
mon père était poète
par ma mère
j'imagine
un amour correspondant pour le théâtre
quand j'étais actrice
par mon grand-père à  que je suis devenu
ve  Je me suis rapproché après la mort de mon père,
euh,
une compréhension croissante,
euh, de l'installation de films britanniques,
il avait été impliqué dans l'industrie cinématographique britannique
quand cela semblait encore
signifier quelque chose en tant qu'Irlandais, que
pensez-vous de la situation politique maintenant que
mon père était  de la République d'
Irlande du sud de l'Irlande et la
plupart de mon temps a été passé dans le
sud
et il est vrai que la vie des
gens du sud n'est presque
pas affectée
par ce qui se passe au-delà de la frontière, j'ai
passé un peu  de temps dans le nord et j'ai
des amis du nord
et euh je sais un peu ce qui se
passe là-bas, cela semble être une
situation insoluble,
c'est terriblement douloureux pour les gens
qui vivent là
-bas et j'ai peur
pour une raison quelconque, je '  J'ai toujours
été en faveur du
nationalisme irlandais et de l'unité irlandaise
et j'espère vraiment que dans
un avenir pas trop lointain, les Britanniques sortiront
d'Irlande, mais en disant que pour le
moment, ce serait impos  sible pour eux
de partir sans l'effusion de sang la plus horrible en
tant que membre du Royaume-Uni, que
pensez-vous des émeutes qui ont eu
lieu le week-end dernier,
je pense que c'est la pointe de l'iceberg, je
pense que
je veux dire que les émeutes concernent la taxe de vote, mais
ils '  Il ne s'agit certainement pas de propriétés, les
gens viennent d'être à bout
de force dans ce pays à
propos de tant de choses différentes
et la plupart des problèmes que l'
on pourrait dire viennent d'en haut,
euh, mais euh,
je pense que les gens
en Angleterre sont en quelque sorte  de redécouvrir
le business de l'émeute
parce qu'il y a une sorte de
Tolérance dans le pays qui est comme une
éponge et ça absorbe toute
possibilité de changement
et euh même si même si beaucoup
de violences qui ont lieu peuvent être
complètement irrationnelles
et sans rapport avec quoi que ce soit de positif,
je suis toujours assez étonné de le voir
quand les gens en Grande-Bretagne le prennent
en main pour essayer d'apporter des changements
de manière violente parce que ça n'arrive pas
souvent  ppen il y a du mal quand
on est un acteur aussi célèbre d'éviter de
devenir une star je veux dire j'ai toujours
réussi à faire le travail que je voulais
faire et personne ne m'a vraiment empêché de le
faire qu'en est-il des filles françaises
qu'en est-il  eux
étrangers